no you're using internet unprotected how
many goddamn times I gotta tell you
check out nordvpn now
thanks to nordvpn all your internet data
stays safe behind Next Level encryption
no one can see what you're doing bro not
even me bro openness as many tabs of
weird stuff that you want they don't
have any Longs strict no Longs you're
good you're that a safe but that doesn't
mean it slows you down you can share
large files of data online no problem it
works on your phone it works on your
computer it's easy to access it's quick
to connect I've been using nordvpn
forever I use it all the time it's a
great product and I think one of the
most important things is that worldwide
access you know sometimes websites likes
to have these dumb ideas to block your
videos in certain countries nordvpn gets
you past that you want access to
streaming different shows in different
countries nor VPN gets you access to
that it only costs a few bucks a month
that's it and right now if you sign up
you get huge discount as always huge and
huge discount okay and four months free
so yeah check out nordvpn and if you're
not sure about it there's a risk-free
guarantee that's right you guarantee to
get your money back try it out if you
don't like it
money back you literally got nothing to
lose to try it out link is in the
description
nordvpn.com PewDiePie they also have
another great service called nordpass
which you also should definitely use
which is a password manager that lets
you securely store all your passwords
and come up with actual good passwords
yeah two great products that you should
use Link in the description thanks so
many band for sponsoring this video
let's get on with the video tick tock
house tour Tick Tock we've done YouTuber
house tour now we do tick tock house
tour Tick Tock eye store how do tick
tockers make money they have money uh
okay let's check this out
this is the sway house tour which is the
Microsoft suede oh no they broke up they
broke up no
this way how uh sway house didn't last
uh rip I got we got the spoilers right
away there's a bunch of dudes they were
uh making Tick Tock stuff together
breaks my heart it really does
[Music]
is that it
they're doing they're doing a b-roll
while uh their Postman is trying to
deliver them packages hey can we deliver
this package no no sorry I just gotta
get this drone shot what is happening
[Music]
Thriller air nice
that's the uh I'm balding but I want to
hide it a haircut so this is one of the
parts
you actually look strict it's a separate
house from all the other house it's our
house in another house basic grimer come
on up right there that is a room right
there right above our garage and it's
actually for uh one of our managers we
were also informed not to cuss so this
is a very shooty car we're freaking
annoyed about it and this is my Tesla my
Tesla is so fast I can't swear so I'm
just gonna speak like a baby uh Anza 100
so there's only 200 bro these haircuts
dude get the out of here
the model Y and it's a lot cheaper and a
way better spend though oh Bryce hey oh
is this the blue machine
oh yeah this is not a house
this is not a house tour
boy I thought it was a house tour the
way you said that
I'm right here and Blake is all the way
over there hey what's up Blake it's
crazy how bright it still looks smaller
than what'd you say that's actually
funny that you say that because that is
definitely not true sorry oh they're so
cringed it's kind of dudes that
definitely I don't know about these guys
but I remember someone sent me like that
was a tick tock house of a bunch of guys
and they all look roided the [ __ ] out
and you can see like they all gain
muscle in like six months too which is
such a uh indicator definitely not true
hey Warren see this seems like a tick
tock thing to do right tick tock roid
house every time I take my dog out it's
weird oh what do you say it's my dog out
to go poop this is so weird I feel like
actually High Pass right now yeah I
can't even cuss
what is high pass then is that another
oh that's the big one that's the one
I've heard about okay okay so these are
the little edgier boys got it
I did we definitely cuss in every single
sentence so where are we going right now
we're going to the house cool that's
really cool that's cool that you guys do
that we are in the living room where
women
with lots of living here
Freeze Frame what can I say it's just so
[ __ ] I hate all of it if you've ever
been to a kid's room uh I was recently
visiting my my sister and my nephews
this is what uh their room looks like
just scattered with like random toys
these guys are adults and he looks the
same it looks exactly the same like how
they would make it making my chair yeah
she's making my chair right now no
that's my chair buddy yep well she
washed an area we actually have stocked
food for once there's someone's job to
build their gamer chairs I love that oh
man so they can just walk around and
think they're cool and [ __ ] it's so
cringe Jesus they must be 16 at least
it's like a frat house I just realized
that's what it is isn't it's what that
says that's what I imagine it is if we
don't have fried
bathroom set up there's a sideways
dollar sign over here oh that's Abraham
Lincoln oh no that's Thomas Jefferson
yeah this is it
this is where Margot Robbie goes in the
bathroom
is that a bathroom
it looks like a entry hall or something
what is that bathroom that's ridiculous
what are you doing there it's bigger
than most people's gyms
[Applause]
oh they have the [ __ ] Japanese [ __ ]
these guys [ __ ] these piece of [ __ ] rat
holes no but for real I can't get past
this bathroom what the what's the who
designed this bathroom why would you
what
ah this is where Margot Robbie goes to
the bathroom when she stays over that's
where she goes to the bathroom because
it's your bathroom is that why or what
was a joke then all right I hope you
guys enjoyed that house awesome I am
heartbroken that they broke up moving on
to something hopefully a bit more chill
which is uh Dixie damilio hello
guys it's sexy wait is she a YouTuber or
a tick Tucker she's a singer known for
her social media Tick Tock but she's not
she's a singer
[Laughter]
whatever you want apparently put me
PewDiePie genius it's still not
completely finished and I'm moving out
in a couple months so then to watch the
point of showing it I don't give a [ __ ]
God damn it
stop showing if you're moving out
you break all the fun from me
and also if you live in America where
the F would you live in a flame unless
you live in New York my living room all
my furniture is from Tov so like my
couch is from Top these chairs are from
top that's really good I always want to
know the brand of people's Furniture the
first thing they do in a tour oh what a
lovely hat what's the what's the
important insurance brain it's about to
be Tau you better [ __ ] be Tom put
these together
I wanted it to look wait did she say
that she put them together and she
didn't have someone hired to build their
furniture for them I actually put these
together
wow that's incredible hey
now that I think about that I would
actually love to have that job I love
building Furniture it's the best I
wanted it to look cool but I also didn't
know what to do right here is where I
stand most mornings I drink my morning
coffee and stare into other people's
Apartments sometimes we make eye contact
sometimes we don't it's kind of like a
little game I play you know this is a
pop that's super weird maybe that's why
people are like living in an apartment
they like staring at people this is my
dining room table Tav again chairs are
from Tov it's got a small flat isn't it
it must be really downtown things
underneath at least it feels small
looking at it this is all my music stuff
I have my triller built I've not heard a
single song Let's do be happy it's not
great I have my be happy plaque for 300
million worldwide streams which is cool
over here we have a water so you really
fill those Corner in with that random
luxury products like oh I have a corner
put a popcorn machine there if I had a
place like that I would want to put like
some maybe built in some sort of sofa
and you can sit by the window maybe read
look out that'd be cozy it's just weird
putting appliances in a corner like that
like she said she enjoys looking at as
well and a candle baseball bat so this
baseball bat is from the boy music video
I broke a pinata with it at the release
party that's the story behind the bat
that's sick that's such a good story
better hang on to that bat look how
close it is that her apartment or is
that actually a neighbors because that's
really awkward to be that close I've
washed my dishes once and I posted it
like spilled all over the ground all the
bubbles like like flew everywhere and
that was like the first day of living
here by myself she doesn't use a
dishwash it because it doesn't work but
if she bought this place surely someone
should just come in and fix it right I
don't get it I usually keep it really
clean it's not clean right now because I
haven't gone grocery shopping and I
usually do that after I go grocery
shopping or like I get groceries you
just have liquids which I do respect I
would also only have use a fridge for
drinks mostly drinks right now and like
cheese Charlie got this for me for my
birthday I got this couch and it's
really cute because it's like a cloud
Charlie got this for my birthday I'm
like what the [ __ ] is it turn it on
please
all my hoodies and a lot of shoes in
here towels leggings it's just a lot
easier keeping it all in one place it's
easier to have all your clothes in one
spot I'm so confused what is she saying
I get so bored I zone out if you have 80
ADHD you understood what I was saying
machine must be
it makes sense at the time and then you
listen and then think what was I saying
and that's what happened but yeah this
is the Glam room so she said a bunch of
dumb [ __ ] in any of you and the way here
she addresses is like uh yeah ADHD you
speak a lot and that was dumb okay great
I can't be held out accountable for what
I say I have ADHD dream cause it to look
like very organized finger spaced
hangers finger spaced hanger
ah fumes my two favorite are
well my favorite one's not even here but
it's the Ariana Grande Cloud perfume
it's really good and she has a new one
coming out so wait what was that again
and then the Fenty Rihanna perfume that
okay okay got it good but yeah it's the
most what cute little decoration it
smells good okay got it just like things
looking good oh it's so good thanks
right now but it's cute and then over
here I have like all my storage of my
high school diploma and my little Castle
High School
laughs it's a good high school diploma
maybe High School is different in
America
everyone does
[Music]
it's really cool my mom got it for me I
have an ice cream bin I think there's
like travel bags in here she loves
showing stuff that really doesn't matter
like she's not even interested in it
herself this mirror changes I don't use
it okay cool my back wall most of these
are either gifted from the brands or
presents this is the hat from the F Boy
music video I love that when you're rich
you don't have to pay for stuff anymore
it's like a dream wall for a lot of
girls I bet and then it's like I got it
all for free I got someone painted all
my dogs on it and it's really cute my
headboard is from Tav or my beds from
Tov my comforter yes I was just about to
ask and I'm so glad it's from Tom what
the [ __ ] is Tom it's the same one I had
at home in Connecticut but this is
Calvin Klein it actually was really hard
to find oh it's Calvin Klein exciting
but they like stopped selling it so I
had to get it from like I could sleep
safe at night knowing Dixie the Amelia
sleeps in kelvin Calvin Klein bed linen
but yeah everything's really black and
white I don't love like too much color
in anything because I feel like it makes
it look messy sometimes so she really
hates messy stuff
it seems like she must have a hectic
life if you want to keep your home so so
neat and organized like everything seems
to have a specific spot she seemed
really really into it and also the fact
that she won in her bedroom to be
exactly like the old one she had kind of
also shows that she needs that Comfort
at home because the outside world like
she talks about all these paintings and
just to remind her that it is to have
fun and that she she is enjoying herself
I don't know I'm getting like super
awkward like she hates all of this Vibes
so that's fun and there's like a camera
but I keep it covered
because it's weird then show it I want
to see how it works come on that's the
only thing the only item I was
interested in it's super right now it's
kind of stressing me out because it
doesn't look like how I would want it to
look yeah that's way too messy I would
be stressed to break out if my closet
looked that messy my God it's barely
color coordinated but I have all my
clothes pants skirts I thought you said
it was easier to have all your clothes
in one spot I'm so confused what was the
whole point my silver jewelry if I'm
wearing it I usually take it off right
after I'm done wearing it because I get
very overheated and like rip it off so I
try not to wear any jewelry that I love
like she's extremely boring my God but
this is clearly for young girls who
would be I love this kind of thing I'm
sure I like them like she's a neat freak
I do respect that okay cool moving on to
the hype house
this is with Entertainment Tonight
exclusive let's go BT welcome to the
hype house wait is the hype house still
a thing they're moving to Italy dreams
really do come true either way I don't
care I'm gonna watch this Thomas let's
get a tour
[Music]
all right this is the crew
damn so many [ __ ] people what the
hell like worse than you thought S Club
7 was bad my name's Nick Austin
my name is Chase
this is the show cut a Showcase of their
work
[Laughter]
oh my God they are the ones that make
the worst Tick Tock these these guys are
the reason everyone hates Tick Tock like
miming and awkwardly dancing
well over a thousand tick tocks have
been made in our bathroom in the first
like two months of living here not
downstairs has probably been like like
some people are genuinely good dancers
on Tech talk and it's fun to watch sure
but like these are so good
it
is
like two months of living here now
downstairs has probably been like 100
minutes out in our living room why is it
so funny
um but when we first moved in everyone
would just come in here you'd wake up to
people being in here you'd go to sleep
with people going in your bathroom
turning on the lights and filming so
they are all filming in the bathroom
because that's the only place that had
good lighting and Lord knows people need
good lighting right here this is our
Goose his name is Jerry we take baths in
here sometimes I've actually never taken
a bath in there once
you just said we take bass in there and
then you say you don't ever take a bath
in there cool hey that's false that's
false we took one in there we were doing
a Coke and Mentos oh that's false they
did take one cool no then over here is
my sink
and this is my ring light these are our
lights in our mirror it's very big and
this is our green marble I think it is
countertop it's always good to get a
tour from someone who clearly has like
they don't give a [ __ ] uh okay so this
is my office it's got a mirror it's it's
big uh uh I got a chair which I sit in
and I got this is my microphone and I
speak and you can hear me uh I have
walls surrounding me there's a door to
enter and leave
um
and yeah that's pretty much it this is
our shower it has two shower heads wow
uh Thomas is so cool he also lives here
and here is a toilet and a bidet I'm not
going to show you because that's nasty
and that's pretty much the whole
bathroom why is it nasty why how dirty
is your [ __ ] toilet oh no they have
what I don't understand these kitchens
look this is a modern kitchen and they
still went with dark wood I I'll never
understand dark wood some pile of dishes
always
um and apparently this is the fridge it
kind of looks like a cabinet but it's a
fridge
and it doesn't smell very good in there
there's like nothing yeah yeah bro
instead of hiring people building your
furniture hire someone to clean out your
goddamn breaks hot sauce and cookie
dough we'll bring our Postmates straight
into here and then we'll just kind of
hang out and eat like sit on the
counters or whatever but really we kind
of hang out everywhere like I swear to
God modern houses will not have a
kitchen everyone will just there will be
some version of like a deliveroo thing
no one will have a kitchen anymore
that's less weird than everyone have in
the kitchen that they don't use
right we started this as a group of
friends to make content to have a good
time to do something that no one else is
doing amazing people have been saving up
their whole life for a house like that
and a bunch of teenage got it because
they danced on the night
yeah nah all right I'm not hating on
young people getting rich this is very
funny it's better than all these Boomers
it's kind of hard to rate that house
because all they did was really talk
about themselves but uh yeah that was
tick tock house tour awful subscribe for
more check out other videos I've done
the house tour and uh see you next time
bye bye oh hit the Bell thing hit the
Bell thing I don't know what that means
I don't know how you do it hit the Bell
thing thanks I have new merch
represent.com super happy about this one
I think you guys will like it check it
out